同オンなるほど水族館デートしたい
これじゃあ肇社長ですというわけで今日は
ですねこちら八景島シーパラダイスさんに
また来ておりますよろしくお願い致します
はい海の生き物たちピンにイルカさん宅と
もふれあえる素敵な場所なんですけども
持続館の水槽といろんなやつがあるんです
よ壁がずっと広がってる奴とかいじカレー
たに上りつつ見れるやつはいろんな水槽
あるともですけども
もしもしツイートはれから怖くないいうか
まずないんですけど水槽を割るとマージで
強いと思うんですよそんな的な準備は水素
があるわけじゃないんです水素もちろん
ありませんけども水槽を割るなって思う
ような仕掛け今回ずう見させていただき
ましたこちら
car
[音楽]
wh
dj ん
はいっ
おのれグァの準備されていただきましたね
特殊な技術さんに作っていただいたんです
けどもアーティジョンのついストールじゃ
ないですかそこの水そんなガラス割れたら
マジで怖いと思うんですよ僕だったら絶対
出資しますだって想像してみこの年弁部は
れって水ギター本当に濃いと思うんで
そんな今日も今回後輩に体験していただき
たいだと思います僕だったら切れてますと
いうわけでなんかテキトーなぁ企画を説明
して後半横のアーチジョージ水槽に持って
きます水上被って日々はれるとなんか水が
滴ってくる気がするので
こっちが水鉄砲結婚後に水だけでは
[音楽]
この言葉ものこと
食べますかなこの3つのした彼がいいん
ですよ言われているものから水が認める
ことによって力のあっちょうそだと言わ
れるんじゃないかといって妄想してしまう
んじゃないかと思うんですよというわけで
早速
時
ハーレ
[音楽]
なんでそんなに笑っているいやエッジが
笑ったよえこういう彼はなんだかもと思っ
ていますし
が気がしないと思う怒られるぞ
5門限できるは士族が後ろからあると
めちゃくちゃ気持ち悪くなれず
ずっとの傷で
するときは後ろ向きでこうやってたら
まっすぐ歩くと本当にいい感じですけど
後ろ向きで歩くとめちゃくちゃ気持ち悪く
なる済む
[音楽]
[拍手]
いやねその魚の泳ぐ方向と弱に凝っていく
から
どんなんだぞ
距離が何て言うの
わかる離れてく距離が凄いそうか外は
すごい咲く花とかい気もか動いたにいい
こっちは下がっているのに一緒に下がる
みたいと距離感がおかしくなってめちゃ
気持ち悪くなるって言う話を聞いたので
超ソロですね
本当にデパスのふーん
覆いかぶさるんだよなるほど海が確かここ
で後継者必要ですねちょっとだけ素者です
かぷりてぃんだけどした畑走る武器で歩い
て気持ちよくなっちゃったってことが起き
た
バージョンそれ起きません2年間もっと
情報で低い届きでしゃがんでる信号報告弱
そう
で持ち歩くなるところ
男性も座ってるからそれと思いますね
ね線は祝下がるとか引き続きやっていき
ましょう
ほんと月結構カツ
県展を逆あるというこっから英軍水族館な
んだよあまたしかし血圧遺族からもう緑化
そうですか方ケースでのデートみたい
なかったはいは再構成してね長賞
水雑貨なんて一つ目ですね
こっちから行くよ
タンカー鍋だよ
癒しさにしたた街でどうだってほらもう
作って言ってもいるところん底の底ば買っ
た
髭原人
がとってほんと継承をやってるんだよ作す
るッギャベないので真似しないでください
これ見ていい御先祖冊にこうやって言って
みるあーなるほどほらほらグーッと
鈴木集めればわかるんです
あがすげーへい
月で凄い凄いわ
デートもサイドもあるんだどっちコーデ
新しいせずこそ面白いの白いのでカーでか
笑顔だ笑顔有働へ自分だ
中国側にこれ言えないところあるプーの
タム不快感の要因でことうーんなるほどね
見てればいいかんねっ
そこにでなアーチすごいーっ
あああああいうこれをこういうこれもさあ
こうやっているとすごいはけどいいから
地下にいいから
here ここだけを後ろ向きかあったら
全部かあああああ
ぬーっに
を
応援を秘密方が
おい
[音楽]
おおおおおおおお
彼を大
基本ジャックが内の別
バーガー
僕んん
すごく園に強いへ
うんうん
yeah yeah
ああああああ
ああああああああああああ
yeah
やっぱヤバイ残った普通に終わったと思い
ますね山水画ネイルだったと思うこれこれ
これでしょうねべき人たちました
そしてが入ったすぐ
もじそを伴うとけっこ5
自分で大人聖戦たら先制されてもすぐ入っ
て指で
アーチ型のスイスを追われたら怖いせです
でした
ran
[音楽]
bl立った彼を待ってねしてるは君とした
とっ
なんでこんなとこにいるの
ませんねぇー
[音楽]
[拍手]
あげていいですよいい
[音楽]
行かないん
を笑ってるのねぇ君いい
かわいい
君をは立てるのにいい
やっとできたと思うこんにちはー
まだなさ
あがこのロッツォ増えたったら熱を奪って
います
お願いしますええなぁありませ
ん
まず方へ
[音楽]
ん
食べますバスケットボーラー
あああああ
もうデー
[音楽]
いいいいいいいい
古材
はーいー
うーん混じった1